[Music]
let's hear it for eels as unique to us
as our fingerprints are these cuddly
bendy bits of cartilage called
pinna have grown out of the side of our
heads for good reason
back in the day they helped us hunt by
pinpoint in which direction that
rustling in the bushes was coming from
but perhaps most importantly eels help
us communicate with other human beings
even before we emerge from the womb
we've decided whose voice we like most
it's our mummies and we've probably had
a wee jive to our favorite songs because
our lugs
are already listening when we are minus
20 weeks old
after we're born our sticky out eels
become even more useful
they deflect sound towards your eardrum
keep your glasses from falling straight
off your head
they help us to socialize too the inner
workings of the ear
heighten the frequencies of the human
voice so much so that some scientists
claim that listening to someone
is a more effective way to recognize and
decode complex human emotions
than looking at their facial expressions
but if all the complicated goings on
seem to happen
inside the ear why do they stick out the
side of our heads instead of sitting on
top like a bunny or hanging low like an
elephant
it often comes down to whether an animal
is predator
or prey predators like foxes have ears
on the top of their heads that they can
point down at the ground when hunting
this allows them to hear what poor we
animals are burrowing underground
dig down to get them snack away for
animals that don't need to hunt
eels on the tops of their heads allow
for better movement
a rabbit's ears can swivel 270 degrees
and allow them to hear for up to three
kilometers meaning that they can be
alert for predators
while looking at dinner our old pal the
african elephant has the biggest eels of
any creature on earth
making up about a fifth of the surface
area they use the giant lugs to fan
themselves
while the thin skin does a great job of
dissipating heat
our external wheels may not serve us so
well on a hot day but
they can be an indicator of our health
and in the most
peculiar way it comes in the form of a
diagonal crease on your earlobe called
frank's sign benign as it may look
the appearance of frank's sign has been
linked to cardiovascular disease
and diabetes but scientists are stumped
over why the case appeals and how
it correlates to these diseases just
that it kinda
does now while we're on the subject of
earlobes
decorating them is nothing new for
humans at least
the oldest mummy ever found in europe
otzi
the iceman had pierced heels
and modern times because we're so damn
edgy we found about 14 different ways to
peel cereals
each with their own name the most funny
the bunch might be
tragus the word comes from the ancient
greek
tragos meaning goat apparently because
the tuft of hair some people have coming
from their ears
looks like a goat's beard if the idea of
piercings
makes you wince cover your ears now and
be glad you still have them because
if you were a criminal in 16th century
england
there was a chance your punishment would
be cropping
that's where your eels were cut off to
show the rest of the town who the
delinquent was
you would even prescribe the haircut so
you couldn't hide your shame
but for the uncropped our eels never
stop growing
maybe good news if you've got incy wincy
heels but for the already large lugged
they ain't going away and gravity is
only going to make them get floppier as
you age
big or small it's the shape and folds of
your ear
and how the brain processes sound waves
that help us determine where a sound is
coming from
so next time you lose your phone under
the sofa it's your twisty earphones
that are helping you to locate that
coldplay ringtone
such sounds might be painful to hear
physically even if they're over 130
decibels
but our strange we ears give us lots to
be thankful for
they allow us to hear our loved ones and
best of all
pretend not to hear them when you said
you'd hang the washer
you